[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So hi, we're
here back at dotJS
in an amazing venue,
and I'm here with
Nicolas to talk
about Dart, which is the
topic of the session you just
gave at the conference.
So, for those that
have been living
under a rock, that have
not heard of Dart 1.0
being released first of all,
and maybe Dart in general,
can you give us a quick
intro to what this really is?
Is it just a language?
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY:So
Dart is a language,
a new programming language.
But it's not just a language.
It contains lots of tools
around the language,
like an IDE, a
lightweight IDE, where
you can do refactoring,
debugging, completion, code
completion.
There's also a
compiler to JavaScript.
So you can run your code
on any modern browser.
And we have what we call a VM,
which is really an accelerator,
that will run your Dart
code really fast in Chrome.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So a new language
that can compile to
JavaScript, I suppose
this is what most
people will do today.
Can you tell us about the
differences between language
that will be compiled to
JavaScript in terms of workflow
development and performance
versus maybe using
the VM as a native execution?
What are the differences here?
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY:So when
you compile to JavaScript,
you're obviously limited
to JavaScript performance,
the performance of the
runtime underneath, right?
There has been a
lot of work going on
to make JavaScript really
fast in the last few years.
But we designed the language
with performance in mind.
The background of
the Dart designers,
they've implemented virtual
machines for many years.
They've done Hotspot,
they've done V8.
So when we designed this
new language, we said, OK,
how can we make that
language really fast?
And what you have
for the Dart VM--
and you can actually see
the numbers on our page,
dartlang.org-- is
it can run code
twice as fast as JavaScript.
We have a set of
benchmarks that we chose.
And you can see the
evolution over time.
And you can see initially
we were really--
compared to JavaScript--
really bad because we were just
starting the project.
But over time, like in
a year, we caught up,
and now we're like
two times faster.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
How about VM performance?
You said it's an accelerator,
how much improvement can
we expect?
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY:
That's two times faster.
The ones you can expect--
you can see the trend
on that graph, which is like
it's getting better and better
every day.
So it's hard to say a number,
but a 2x, 3x performance
improvement is something
you can think of.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Right,
and the VM is something you
can use today, at least when
you develop, or if you control
the deployment environment.
I think the work
now is to get this
into main Chrome, which
is-- it's not there today.
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: Yes.
It's not there today, there's
a lot of technical things
that need to be fixed in
Chrome to get the Dart
VM into the browser.
We have a project
called [INAUDIBLE],
which is basically a
revamp of the memory
management in our
Blink engine in Chrome.
And it will enable running
two different languages,
like JavaScript and Dart,
inside the same browser.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
So can you talk about-- I
think the Angular team also
is working with Dart,
and how are they
using their two technologies,
and what are they using it for?
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: So
the Angular team, they
have this project
called AngularJS
that started before Dart.
And once they saw Dart being
this very interesting platform,
they decided to go for Angular
to Dart as well, so that they
can offer-- if you want
JavaScript, you have AngularJS,
and if you want Dart,
you have AngularDart.
So as of today, I think
the JavaScript version has
more features than the
Dart one, but the Dart one
is trying to keep up to
what the AngularJS has.
Internally at Google, we
have built an app, just
based on Dart and AngularDart.
That was a few weeks ago.
We had someone from Google
presenting how to use Dart
and how to use
AngularDart to build
that-- it was a
sales application.
And they were really amazed
about how productive they were.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Right, I
heard things about
an entire team
being brought to
develop a critical app,
because this is about the ads
division vision at Google.
And they had no prior knowledge
of neither Angular nor Dart,
actually.
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: Yeah, I
think their background was more
about Java, so the
app used to be in GWT.
And they switched to Dart
without knowing the language,
or AngularDart without
knowing the framework.
And the number that they
gave us is that it took them
six months to build the app
from scratch, dogfood it.
And the dogfood went
pretty smoothly,
and they were able
to just launch it.
So now pretty much
everyone uses it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Great, so it's definitely used,
at least internally, at Google.
So you didn't wait
for a 1.1 version
to talk about performance.
I mean it's really a
feature from the beginning
and-- not even 1.0--
it was, as you said,
something you looked at when
you designed the language.
Tell me, maybe for
Dart-to-JS, which
is the compiler to JavaScript,
which you've been heavily
involved in-- give me an example
of what kind of optimization
you're doing there that is
really proving to be useful
performance-wise.
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: So the nice
thing about the Dart language
is that it operates in a
closed world environment.
So when you're
compiling to JavaScript,
you can make a
lot of assumptions
of things that will
happen at one time,
like you know that certain
fields will never change,
or certain fields will
always get that type.
So you can do these kind
of global optimizations,
for example, tree
shaking, type referencing,
all those nice standard compiler
optimizations that JavaScript
engines cannot do because they
don't have this closed world
assumption.
So dart2js implements all
these compiler optimizations
and generates a JavaScipt code
that sometimes actually runs
faster than the
JavaScipt version
that you would write by hand.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, great.
So how about the tooling, is
there anything you recommend?
You mentioned an IDE-- web
developers don't really
like IDEs, I mean the
term, they have tools,
but they don't call them IDEs.
Do you force people to use an
IDE before they can use Dart?
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: No,
no, no, no, we don't.
Actually, I code in Vi
as well, because that's
my work environment,
my workflow.
So you can code in Vi, Emacs,
whatever editor you like.
We also have plug-ins
for different IDEs,
on the names I don't
have right now,
but you're not just
forced to use that IDE.
You don't have to use an IDE.
You can actually also
use the command line
and run an analyzer that
will analyze your source code
and tell you where
your errors could be.
So, no, we don't force
anyone into using the IDE.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Awesome.
So maybe one final question
before we wrap this up.
Is Dart just meant
to be a web language,
or can you imagine using it
maybe on the service side
to write command line tools?
It seems generic enough
to be able to do that.
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: Yes,
it is generic enough.
So Dart started as a
solution to all the problems
we saw with web development.
So that's why we started
Dart with web in mind.
But it can actually do
way more than just web.
It can run standalone, so you
can run the VM standalone.
You can actually build a
server, so if you know Node.js,
that's really similar.
You can build a
service side Dart code.
We have IO libraries that
do files, sockets, HTTP.
So it's pretty much ubiquitous.
It can be run anywhere.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Very good.
Well congratulations on
the launch of Dart 1.0,
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: Thank you.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
I hope it all goes well.
Looking from the workshop
that was done here at dotJS,
it was completely packed.
So there was definitely
a lot of interest there--
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: They were
blown away by the technology.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
Let's hope we have a lot
of other people interested
in this.
And with that, that's all
the time we have for it.
Thank you, Nicolas.
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: My pleasure.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And go and check it out,
dartlang.org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]